haha my name's we're back
welcome to condom we arrived at this
firehouse and we're supposed to look for
clothes by following the babka
righteousness I think I will go with you
you look like a fine pack
we'll look you grew up - I like it very
sexy all right god this house is really
creepy but that's okay that's what I do
it's my my thing
creepy stuff going floor intuitive here
there's nothing skating
are you joking with me oh I take photos
it's fun the dark path there we go it's
a good pad alright surgery um yes easier
to find two of them it was kind of a
boring process so I figured why not why
I show all of it okay let's go back
downstairs find the last piece of the
puzzle I don't remember which one I
haven't followed maybe this one I have a
faint memory of following that mic there
fine line have a memory of following it
go through the wall what am I supposed
to do eat the wall but I don't like what
no no I get it I go on the other side
it's too bright in here
wait actually not and then it goes back
anyway thank you line thank you for
telling me you
but now what is this line
don't tease me line this one is
difficult look at that
you can climb well line like a line of
alright here we go
oh [ __ ] anyone in here it's just an
empty house no creepy stuff in it
Oh kids stop that's not creepy a little
light is listed oh my gosh got a box
I love boxes budet I can't all right
the final treasure lies beyond this stop
I'm attack whoa it's a pony
I love it put it now Ola bruh
go crazy I have immediate whoa this is
mediocre passion for ponies sorry miss
Chad about that sorry about that
nothing creepy about the Attic beautiful
all right so where is the line hairiness
gotta follow the line got shine for the
line hey man
oh it's anemia guys oh [ __ ] the Nina guy
it's not good this is not good this is
not good
sledge okay stop okay oh you see that
[ __ ] oh he's period is a power you got
pick at your power you may have ninya
power if I have to pick at your powers
all right final batch up again
blockage this is [ __ ] difficult
oh I got your nunchuck look at me I'm
Nina - boom I don't like that guy if you
don't like it then shoot a puta follow
the thing I get feeling this how do I
get past that nunchuck come on brah
don't sneak up on me how'd this one go
through there maybe there's another line
we can follow
I've been following lines for hours come
on maybe there's a secret path over here
except I don't have the stamina her
Marnie
that's the breakdancing going girl not
very good I see whoo all the birds all
the single birds all the single birds
all the single birds
oh hang back put your hands up come on
key bar
oh it is finding what if I can't you run
through it two boxes come on back this
hole you see this better box is better
recognize
huh maybe I need sled she for the well
maybe uh I mean come on oh wait there's
something here how am I supposed to go
out here
come on I need a pass
maybe this light bulb is trying to hide
something from me
come on lightbulb that's an impenetrable
lightbulb it's okay
sick of this place
come on what do you want from me huh I
don't know I can't take a joke either I
give up I give up flying box
that's enough that's enough boxes don't
fly man what the hell has this world
come to that boss battle is [ __ ] lame
keep the gas oh I'll grab his [ __ ]
stick then yeah Matt stick wait a second
wait a sec had it have it no mine fine
what No
I did fight me fight me I know you're in
here you know your energy on oh boy well
I slide you can oh you like that [ __ ]
you like that [ __ ] look like someone
peed on your piano dental problem piano
any more lines to follow well of course
lines don't stop there's gotta be
something else a clue or something fire
really
oh there's the line it goes back up no
it opens here there right news near I
did it by myself now take me away please
oh no it's beyond what you see yourself
I know
no you can start searching the house he
just used Google they don't ya keep the
dark path to righteousness beyond which
you're I know no riddles please keep
touching the hand chicken how the
computer keeps you well maybe it's you
maybe it's all about the boxes oh you
like that lamp
that's our bro all right what do you
want I might have something yes the dark
path to righteousness is beyond what you
see
uh-huh maybe it's silly think about it
something and what you see yourself to
be oh I came there are no mirrors in
here I'll just have to find a mirror all
right find a mirror all right
I'm the mirror mat hate this house can I
just look at the reflection of the
window
another
all right maybe there's a mirror down
here
I need crowbar for that [ __ ] no mirror
come on I'm gonna stick of it all right
I'll go down
I know those little [ __ ] are down
here though and I don't like it is this
Beryl I found you secret Wow what is
going on here evidence everywhere
Dutch damn it looks uh what yeah what
there look at this so much evidence oh
my god
more evidence it's me why is it me there
huh you tell me
all right I'm sick of this place can I
go now it looks like it's about me yes
like scan there's a few newspaper
stories about your investigations yes I
got internal bureau newsletter articles
on your career progress precautions
uh-huh the last few pages are newspaper
clippings about serial killers not being
found well some of these are circled in
red with exclamation point beside them
it looks kind of like our serial killer
axe has been following your life and
career pretty closely and he likes me
and why maybe he likes a challenge
exactly maybe he's chosen you to go up
against studies trying to understand his
enemy maybe but my god that seems more
to it than a
and clothes that I come on I'm sick of
investigating are you doing out there
huh what you're doing out there what you
doin out there be back a lot speedy
Jesus Christ even last forever
I know what did they do I have a period
fight again those scumbags never die
well what the [ __ ] what am I supposed to
do Cole Rose I'm really tired of this
room please just let me go let me go
home I used the oven good for them
investigate the noise they said it will
be funny nice
God please whoa I can't take this
anymore
that's my ears what is money
stop complaining what is go yeah
why who said that whoa that's the piano
yeah I know what are you doing no no no
Viviana closed one find an axe and cut I
don't know where there's an axe really
tired of this I'm taking anything I'm
okay but anyway thank you very much
enjoy this guy come ready Jane I'll see
you next episode oh Emily the Ottenberg
mine activate that one's a little more
Smee bra bra bra bra bra whoa Wow